asum
brother according to a Hadi those who
draw pictures will be in Hellfire so
what about the teachers or as a mother
when we have to draw pictures to teach
the
children ask very good question there
sayth which say that anyone who is a
m who draws a picture or a portrait it
will be asked on the day of judgment
that put life in them and all these are
disire it's a
but there are always exceptions to the
rules there are other say Hadith in
which we find Hadith
inkari in say had of Abu da pleased with
her the prophet permitted her even to
play with the toy or there was a horse
without wings so for children there is
an exception to the rule that for the
children if they play with toys Etc
which may resemble
Idols it's permitted and even for the
mother of the
children it clearly mentioned the Hadith
furthermore if you extend it even
includes the teachers of the children so
if a teacher does a drawing or makes a
sculpture of clay modeling whatever it
is for the purpose of Education only
it's allowed but if a teacher does
painting and sells in the market for
earning money that's totally Haram so if
a mother or a teacher to educate the
child does some portrait does some
painting etc for the children as long as
they're young it's permitted in Islam
but not for selling in the market then
that Hadith will be liable that Allah
will ask you to put life in that picture
and your destination will be hire hope
to answer the question